leaders all over the world prepared
their private jets over the weekend to
head off to the cp28 global warming
conference in Dubai some Travelers out
of Munich however had a bit of trouble
taking off as snow blanketed the airport
tipping at least one private jet
backwards in the apocalyptically hot
snow and ice for a group of people who
claimed to fear the heat the Arabian
Peninsula might seem like a strange
place to hold a conference traveling
there private jets which spew as much as
20 times the carbon into the atmosphere
as commercial air travel per passenger
also seems like a strange way to fight
so-called climate change it's almost as
if and I'm not the first to suggest it
the climate religion is not actually
about the
environment many conservatives look at
this kind of hypocritical behavior and
conclude that global warming alarmists
John kery Al Gore all the liberal Elite
that they don't actually believe their
own rhetoric I'm not so sure of that
though and the reason is that everyone
has to believe in something all human
conflict ultimately is theological all
human beings live According to some view
of morality and humanity and the cosmos
it's not possible to avoid
that most people are not all that
logical or coherent about their beliefs
what the climate alarmist Elites will
tell you John KY has actually said this
on camera is that their own pollution
does not really matter one way or the
other for the fate of the world that the
only way to stop global warming is to
get whole Nations whole continents to
get the whole world to stop polluting
they tell you individual Behavior
doesn't matter the only thing that
really matters is collective
action and this tracks with virtually
all leftwing
thinking it might be wrong to commit
murder but as the British radical TP
Thompson said in a quote wrongly but
understandably attributed to Stalin one
must break some eggs to make an omelet
Pagan tribes for all of history have
worshiped nature it's the oldest false
religion in the world and the reason
that the climate religion has once again
come to dominate world affairs is not
just because of the duplicity and greed
of politicians that's another
unfortunate fact that has already always
existed the real reason is that our
civilization has lost faith in the true
religion that supplanted nature worship
so long as that Trend continues expect
more alarmism more Jets and more snow
I'm Michael nolles this is the Michael
nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers head on
over to goodranchers.com subscribe today
with code nolles kerw to claim your free
Limited stock holiday ham before it
sells out Joe Biden is saying that we
ought to consider making Aid to Israel
conditional we'll get to that in just a
moment first though speaking of leaders
and followers you got the climate
leaders going to Dubai going going in
their private jets to one of the hottest
places on Earth to fight the sun monster
but then you've got the the followers
and the followers don't have private
jets and the followers don't go to Dubai
the followers are very very concerned
that if we don't open up the caps on our
plastic water bottles everyone is going
to die of thirst I just picked this up
it's a full bottle of water and I'm on
this quest to dump out any water that
gets trapped in the plastic because once
it's trapped in these PL plastic bottles
we now have lost it basically forever so
it's really important when you see hi
doggo when you see water that's
discarded to open it up and dump it
out um
alternately make sure that when you're
done with water and that goes for like
you know juices or sports drinks or
whatever dump that sh out if you're not
going to use use it because if you don't
it's it's trapped forever and we've lost
that water um to our ecosystem so
thanks I'm no ecological expert I don't
think the water is lost
forever I think the vast majority of it
just gets kind of crushed up and
expelled at landfills and recycling
plants and other garbage facilities and
I I think I think we're going to be okay
on the water I don't think that your
tightening a a plastic Poland Spring cap
is going to uh cause all of us to die of
thirst what is this how is this woman so
worried about your plastic water bottles
this is the climate religions version of
scrupulosity scrupulosity is is an
obsession over sin a a a neurotic
obsession over sin so in True Religion
you you would be obsessed with whether
you had uh wished death on somebody
whether you had stolen something whether
you had had impure thoughts whether you
had violated actual moral laws and in
the climate religion which is a parody
of religion it it's a a parody of True
Religion and it's a a re return I
suppose of the old nature worshipping
Pagan religions there what you obsess
over is whether a drop of water got
stuck in your your bottle before you
sent it off to the landfill this is Peak
neurosis and they don't stop to think
that hold on a second I'm worried about
a drop of water in my water bottle
meanwhile John kery is flying off to
Arabia in a private jet spewing 20 times
the pollution into the air that he he
would otherwise spew if he were flying
commercially huh he's he doesn't care
about this that much why should I care
about this this very minor thing they
don't really think about that because
they they buy the the argument and the
argument has a kernel of truth to it
John KY is right when he says my private
jet isn't going to cause the end of the
world that's true his private jet is a
drop in the bucket when we talk about
pollution also all the private jets
aren't going to cause the end of the
world also all the plastic water bottles
are not going to cause the end of the
world also the nature worshipping Pagan
religions are false and they were
supplanted for a Time by by by the True
Religion and now we're living in
something much closer to the earliest
days of Christianity than we are to say
a thousand years ago or 500 years ago at
the very height of Christian
civilization we are living in A A A
Brave New World animated by a different
set of beliefs and you're seeing this
not just in the environmental nonsense
you're seeing this more distressingly in
other aspects of life including touching
on the family right now
IVF and surrogacy have returned to the
news for reasons that we don't have to
get
into this is to me the clearest example
of moral confusion not just in our
culture but even on the right there are
many people on the right many prominent
conservatives who don't understand why
IVF and surrogacy and a market for
couples who otherwise can't have
children like homosexuals to purchase
babies why that is wrong they don't
quite understand it there's a guy
Richard hanania who is a I guess you'd
call him a right-wing liberal
commentator and here was his I think
sincere confusion on why conservatives
would oppose IVF and
surrogacy he says let me try to
understand the social conservative
position on reproductive issues abortion
should be banned so poor people can be
forced to give birth IVF and surrogacy
should be banned to prevent smart and
successful people from reproducing do I
have that
right uh no he does not have that right
the reason that
conservatives oppose abortion and IVF
and surrogacy is because we believe that
people are not property to be purchased
and discarded at
will that's why that's what unites those
two issues that's what unites the
broader sexual ethic among conservatives
what used to what used to inform the
civilization that used to be called
Christendom that is why it's wrong and
it's not just the homosexuals who have
to recognize it should get to in one
second first though when you want to
treat your body right you got to check
out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code NES what do
green eggs and your Christmas dinner
have in common they both need a ham to
be complete not just any ham a spiral
cut Heritage pork Masterpiece from good
ranchers that's the kind of ham that'll
steal the show at your family gathering
and guess what you get it for free with
any good Rancher subscription that's a
whopping $99 value that you get for free
in your first order simply subscribe to
any box you will get your free holiday
ham included in any order get 25 bucks
off every order a free gift in every
third box and free shipping on express
delivery the best part is knowing
exactly where your meat comes from which
is a local American Farm head on over to
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code nolles kwes to claim your free
Limited stock holiday ham before they
sell out act fast this offer will not
last forever order before December 11th
for guaranteed delivery by Christmas
head to goodranchers.com use code nolles
kwes when you subscribe to get your free
10 pound holiday ham do not settle for
the same old holiday Fair elevate your
Feast with good ranchers this year good
ranchers American meet delivered people
recoil at
the image of two men creating a child
through
IVF for the express purpose of denying
that child his mother people recoil
naturally some people they consciously
recognize why that is so wrong for some
people it's just a Prejudice and it's a
true Prejudice it's called the wisdom of
repugnance we know it's wrong even if
some people can't articulate
why it's it's harder for conservatives
to understand what the problems with IVF
and surrogacy more broadly so it's so
clear when it's two guys who go out to
look at a catalog and they pick some
woman they they're treating women like
objects like Commodities to be purchased
and they say yeah I want a woman with
blonde hair and I want her to have gone
to Princeton and I want her to work in
banking oh yeah maybe we'll get a Future
Finance here in our family and I want
her to have blue eyes and I want her
that's obviously degrading and
dehumanizing then they find some poor
woman who wants to make 20 or 30 grand
often in third world countries or at
least in struggling countries like
Ukraine uh they will say okay I'm going
to pick that woman I'm going to rent her
womb and we're going to implant these
babies uh in her womb and uh then she's
going to gestate our children for nine
months and then we are going to do all
of this with the express purpose of
ripping that child away not only from
his biological mother his genetic mother
whom he'll never know but also from the
nearest thing to a mother he's ever
known the the woman in whose body he has
been whose voice he has heard for N9
months we're just going to rip him away
from that person not give him the
comfort of that person holding him when
he's born and we're going to do that to
satisfy our natural desires but our
disordered Behavior because we have
chosen these two men have chosen to be
in a relationship that is intrinsically
sterile but in order to accommodate
their desires over the needs and best
interests of a child we're going to
create a kid to deny him his mother does
your mother mat do you like your mother
do you think your
mother had any positive influence in
your life growing up well you're denying
that obviously we all do we all love our
mothers even if you have a mother who's
not that great you even you still
probably love your
mother you are now depriving your child
of one of the most important connections
that any being can human being can have
that is obviously terribly terribly
wrong and the men who do this a lot of
them probably don't know that and a lot
of them have been blinded to that and
the culture has told all of these men
that it's totally fine and the culture
has told men that men and women are
totally interchangeable and there's no
difference between them and the culture
is the law has even told men that they
have every right to do this so I don't
even blame them all personally generally
they know not what they do but it's
terribly terribly
evil but put the homosexuals aside for a
second they don't deserve to Bear all
the blame for this because the
traditional view is that IVF and
surrogacy are wrong period for everybody
why is that someone wrote to me said
Michael you know I I can't believe you
said this because I I can somewhat
intellectually understand why IVF and
surrogacy might be bad in theory but
I've got nieces who were conceived
through IVF and I'm glad that my nieces
are alive so go f yourself Michael
because I don't anything that would
allow my nieces to be alive I think is
totally fine you big jerk you Bible
thumping moralizing jerk okay all right
hold on calm down calm down I hear you I
hear
you I'm sure your nieces are
great I'm I'm sure your nieces are are
wonderful I say and your niece your
nieces have a right to life and it's
good that your nieces
exist the problem for IVF and surrogacy
is that no ends no matter how good
justify immoral
means no ends no matter how good justify
actions that are intrinsically evil to
achieve them
this is the same kind of logic that we
would apply to say rape a child who is
conceived in rape I know
some they have a right to life they're
it's very good that they
exist we like these people had your
nieces God forbid been been conceived in
the case of rape you would you would say
that you would say I love my nieces and
how dare you suggest they shouldn't
exist and how dare you say I'm not
suggesting they shouldn't exist I'm not
suggesting they don't have a right to
life I'm not suggesting they're not good
at all but
let's follow this idea to its logical
conclusion does the fact that your
niece's existence is good and they have
a right to
life does that fact justify
rape certainly
not
likewise good ends can be wonderful and
we can celebrate them but they don't
justify immoral means the reason
surrogacy and IVF are immoral is because
they they interfere into the family they
break up the the nucleus the the very
building block of political Society they
separate the reproductive from the
conjugal
act they establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human
life and they can have all sorts of
unintended consequences how every six
months it seems there's some story in
the news about how some couples who did
IVF whoopsy Daisy the test tubes got
switched and an Asian couple gave birth
to a black baby so they knew hold on
this isn't our baby and you know the
black couple gave birth to a red-headed
white baby and then this oh Whoopsie
Daisy we switched the test tubes around
well now there's a legal case who's my
child that's no good why else what what
else are some of the unintended
consequences of IVF well uh usually in
IVF many human beings are created
embryos are made and then you use one or
two of them maybe you try to implant
multiple and then oh too many took okay
so we're going to have to abort a couple
of them or you only do one or two at a
time then you put the rest in a freezer
and okay we actually don't want a third
child so then those human beings remain
Frozen on Ice in perpetuity that's
obviously profoundly
immoral what are some of the other
problems well how how do you think you
get the sperm for IVF listen some of you
might not be as exacting on your views
of sexual morality as say the Catholic
church but uh acts that we would all
agree are at least somewhat shameful you
wouldn't go bragging about them those
are involved in in getting the raw
materials and it's just so damned
clinical and it's just so degrading and
dehumanizing and I cannot stress this
enough it establishes the domination of
Technology owned by private Enterprise
or the state over the very origin and
Destiny of human life which is very very
disordered so hard saying let those who
have ears to hear Let Them hear it but
we all know because it's just so
obviously repugnant that it is wrong for
two guys to create a kid in a test tube
to purchase a woman to to commodify
human beings to treat people as property
it's wrong to do that and we see that
and we we have that natural reaction
well perhaps we ought to apply some
reason then and and uh investigate why
it's wrong and how that might apply to
more people just than the the those who
are a little light in the loafers and
eager to have children uh without doing
the things properly necessary to have
children
okay one way that one can fight against
this new world order that is being
foisted upon us is to mock it which is
what the daily wire has done which is I
won't I won't belabor the point of
bragged about the movie Enough lady
ballers in which I have a very small
Cameo uh has absolutely crushed it in
terms of viewership and box office
earnings uh lady Ballers I don't have
the exact numbers it's daily wi's
biggest launch ever and we've had lots
of hit launches we had the uh we had
Candace Owens is convicting a murderer
we had Candace's George Floyd
documentary we had Matt Walsh's what is
a woman we've had major major releases
Lady B blew them out of the water and
it's it's a mid 2000 style comedy about
men playing women's sports my favorite
review of it though so it's got 97% of
Rotten Tomatoes audiences love
it it's got two critic reviews one
positive one extremely negative the
critics are just ignoring it that's
their strategy but my favorite one uh
was from a lib I think it was actually
Hanan who is Chen yuger the The
Young Turks guys nephew he said that
lady Ballers is like Mrs Doubtfire but
evil and the funniest thing about this
review the ironic thing about this
review is that it reminded me that Mrs
Doubtfire itself is evil because Mrs
Doubtfire promotes divorce do you
remember I hadn't seen Mrs dfire in so
long Mrs Doubtfire is about this family
where a woman divorces her husband and
they got a kid and the husband wants to
see the kid and this wife doesn't want
him to to see the kid so he dresses up
like a woman and becomes a housekeeper
and and so he at least gets to interact
with the kid in this very degraded way
where he has to pretend to be an old
woman and it shows the importance of
family but what's the resolution in the
end the resolution in the end is not
that they get back together as the
parents obviously should for the good of
the child the the resolution in the end
is they're going to be divorced but just
in a in a nicer way they're going to
have the nice kind of divorce it was
just Peak 90s entertainment I think it
may have come out actually in ' 89 but
it was very was just the vibe of the
1990s
Peak mainstream neoliberalism do
whatever you want just don't make me
everyone needs to go to work and just
don't make me pay for it social social
concerns don't matter at all me me me
and that was the conclusion so I like
the comparison to Mrs Doubtfire because
it was crossdressing and it's funny I
guess you would just say though lady
Ballers is like Mrs Doubtfire but good
but good or but wholesome but not
ultimately depraved now when you want to
look good not like Mrs dfire when you
want to look you know like hot and sexy
you got to check out jell right now go
to genucell.com I've got a holiday gift
idea that will make you the hero of the
Season we all know that the Christmas
season can be hectic the shopping the
cooking the never- ending list of things
to do but I have discovered a gift that
is both thoughtful and transformative
that is the gift of J youell skincare
from now until Christmas Jus cell's most
popular package has a special discount
just for our listeners at Jus cell.com
KW treat yourself and your loved ones to
the best skincare in the world those
troubling forehead wrinkles Fine Lines
skin redness and sagging jawline will
disappear right before your eyes with
jus cell's most popular collection Jus
cell promises immediate effects you will
see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back you
deserve to look and fill your best this
Christmas season you know I love the
founder of this company cop a Christian
from Egypt let for the American dream I
love the product they use only the top
quality ingredients go to Jus cell.com
kwes to get this incredible discount
every order today is instantly upgraded
to free express shipping Jas cell.com
today lady Ballers I may have mentioned
it has officially changed the game
thanks to you that the first ever
feature length comedy from DW is one of
the most streamed movies over the
weekend 97% audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes so to celebrate we had to bring
back our best deal of the Year 50% off
annual DW Plus Membership ships do not
wait this offer expires tonight at
midnight when it's gone it's gone with
your dailywire Plus Membership you will
have access to watch The Daily wies
first ever featurelength comedy but
we're not one and done with the comedies
no We've Only Just Begun take a sneak
peek at the daily wi's new animated
comedy series from Adam Corolla Mr
burum just tell me what you need jump
into the first one rolling speed action
Sawbuck looking a little chubby wubby so
I bought him some new food it's organic
and vegan dogs are supposed to eat meat
they're descendants of wolves you ever
see a vegan wolf on the nature Channel
I'm a
vegan coffee is for closers ladies
listen up hey don't make this a prison
hug don't do anything stupid other than
last year I'm a heteronormative
cisgendered white male for which I
apologize I'm black and that used to be
enough but I'm also bilingual and I'm
nonbinary we're the Army we more before
9:00 a.m. than you Navy pukes do all day
he rubbed all the fur off his emotional
support fah the damn thing look like a
four-legged
penis charity and work two words that
should never go together like women and
opinions I want a Burly man they're
salty and make me dizzy sorry just need
to find a thingy to fix my gaming chair
when I was on the construction site my
chair was a 5 gallon bucket was also my
toilet hey I'm done I'm going back to
bed thanks a
lot so I may have snuck a little peek at
Mr burum around these DW offices you
know you go into a back corner you get
you get a cut of the episodes it's
terrific it's just phenomenal get your
DW annual membership today 50% off and
be the first to see all the exciting
content that we have in store for 2024
including Mr burum and the daily wies
highly anticipated series The Pen Dragon
cycle inspired by the renowned works of
acclaimed Christian novelist Stephen R
lawhead we are bringing one of the most
timeless stories of all time to life
with a unique retelling of the Arthurian
Legend but most importantly it's your
chance to join us in the battle to take
back culture and build a future we all
want to see you get all this and so much
more for 50% off today only go to
daily.com subscribe join
now speaking of Changing Times meant to
get to this on Friday but we'll get to
it today the facts have not changed
Henry Kissinger is dead Henry Kissinger
died at age 100 I was able to meet Dr
Kissinger on two occasions one probably
over 10 years ago now and another one I
don't know maybe four or five years ago
uh he was very Charming both times uh
he's F famously a Charming Man I saw him
even at the time he must have been
almost 90 we were at a a big dinner he
and I had had a chance to sit down
together but then we went into the
dinner and I saw this man on his Cane
hobbling around working the room you
know as Charming as ever and people are
of mixed opinion on Henry
Kissinger uh a lot of Libs hate his guts
and anytime any elderly celebrity would
Trend H they would say oh no I hope so
and so isn't dead how come people keep
dying and it's not Henry Kissinger you
know they would joke about this uh even
some conservatives don't like Henry
Kissinger because he had been a fixture
of American foreign policy for so long
some saw him as an emblem of the deep
State I think we're going to miss Henry
Kissinger actually and the reason I
think we're going to miss Henry
Kissinger is because Henry Kissinger for
50 years I guess his career really was
about 75 years he just never stopped man
was Secretary of State to Richard Nixon
but but Henry Kissinger injected into
American foreign policy a strain of
realism a strain of
constraint that many people on the left
and right today refuse to
accept Henry Kissinger was a famous
realist so people attack him for being a
cold warrior and to waging all sorts of
Wars especially in East
Asia but Henry Kissinger was just as
interested in Restraint he was more
interested in Restraint I think than he
was and bombing people the same cannot
be said of the neoconservatives of the
Bush era the same cannot be said of the
liberal imperialists of the Obama era
I'm thinking of people especially like
Hillary Clinton who never met a country
they didn't want to invade and bomb and
tear up and remake after America's own
image their vision of America's own
image not the American founding image
not the vision that has animated America
for most of our history they want to go
fly Pride Flags in
Kandahar Kissinger was not about that
even on the Iraq War which Kissinger
supported Kissinger's justification for
the Iraq War was not the kind of liberal
idealism we heard from the Bush
Administration or that we heard from the
Democrats during the Bush
Administration it was not that we need
to spread democracy and we're going to
turn these pton tribes into thriving
madonian mini republics you know within
5 years or something what we heard from
Kissinger was America was attacked we
need to show tanks rolling through the
Middle East to scare off our enemies
that was it that was his entire argument
Henry Kissinger took realism so far that
he famously during the 1970s told
Richard Nixon that if the Soviet Union
were sending Jews to gas chambers within
its territories that that would not
affect the national interest of the
United States which is ghastly to I
think he later apologized for it it's
ghastly to hear for most people but it
shows you a man who kept the American
national interest at the very four of
his
thinking in a scandalous way actually
and a little bit at least a little bit
of thinking in the National
interest uh is is a very good
thing because when you ignore the
national interest and you only think
about everyone else all around the world
and how we need to send women to school
in Afghanistan and how we need to I
don't know uh carve up China so that the
Dal Lama has a nicer time in tobet
whatever your foreign hobby horse is
then you ignore your your own country
and the country Falls to pot and our
borders break open and our economy
collapses and civil disorder goes
through the roof and there's crime all
over and and then you won't have any
power to to impose any kind of influence
on the world much less to serve your own
constituents Henry
Kissinger what his passing
represents the loss of a a broad
strategic Vision that stretches Beyond
just a year or two that stretches Beyond
even one political party or the other
Henry Kissinger famously had friends in
both polit he was a republican but he
was a Rockefeller Republican and he had
friends in in both political
parties very influential with
Republicans buddies with Hillary Clinton
everybody we we lose that and and so
America
becomes much less strategic both in
terms of its long-term thinking and in
terms of in any way considering its own
national interests I for one pour one
out for Henry the K here's another thing
Henry Kissinger was right about Henry
Kissinger said in the 9s that NATO
should not expand Eastward as the Soviet
Union collapses as the US wins the Cold
War and more importantly even than
winning the Cold War we are able to
watch the uh withdrawal of the Soviet
Union the the decline of the arms race
the widening of American influence
without falling into World War III very
very important and Kissinger along with
other smart people like Sam nun Daniel
Patrick moan George Kenan the author of
The Long Telegram that establishes US
Cold War policy all of them say don't
expand NATO Eastward that will
unnecessarily provoke Russia for no
strategic Advantage whatsoever it will
increase the likelihood of war and guess
what Henry Kissinger sadly was able to
see his prediction proven entirely
correct before his death because the
reason that Russia in invaded Ukraine is
because of all of the sa saber rattling
The Promise by the leader of Ukraine
that Ukraine would join NATO the
European Union and NATO the influence of
the CIA in the midon revolution in 2014
that ousted the pro-russian leader of
Ukraine and installed pro-western
leaders of Ukraine and Russia looking at
that and saying look NATO has already
been encroaching all the way up to our
borders this represents an unacceptable
security risk especially when we're
talking about Ukraine the Bread Basket
of Europe not going to not going to
handle it so then Russia decides I think
in their National interest I'm not
saying it was good or right objectively
I'm not saying the war was justified but
it certainly was in the Russian national
interest to invade
Ukraine at which point Kissinger said
you know this was a major blunder and we
in many ways provoked it by expanding
NATO but the die is cast and now what do
we have we have the NATO Secretary
General saying quote allies agree age
that Ukraine will become a member of
NATO allies agree if the Allies all
agree that means the US agrees I haven't
heard Joe Biden say that publicly we're
now we're now totally on board with
Ukraine joining
NATO that's absolutely insane that's a
terrible idea it provides no strategic
advantage to the United States
whatsoever and it increases the
likelihood of War if Ukraine were to
join NATO today we would instantly be in
World War
III because it would it would trigger
the mutual security comp compact Ukraine
is currently an occupied country we
would immediately be at
War but we don't have a lot of strategic
thinking these days we have a lot of Pie
in the Sky abstract idealistic
ideological thinking based on false
premises and we're going to miss people
like Henry Kissinger hated though he may
have been in many corners speaking of
foreign alliances Joe Biden has just
proposed something that
is really UNP popular in both parties in
many quarters of the American public and
that is to make Aid to Israel
conditional I've encouraged the prime
minister to
uh to focus on trying to reduce the
number of calies while he is attempting
to eliminate Hamas which is a legitimate
objective he has that's a difficult task
and uh I don't know how long it will
take my expectation and hope is that as
we move forward the rest of the Arab
world and the region is also putting
pressure on all sides to slow this down
to bring this to an end as quickly as we
can Mr President what are the chances of
this tro to be extended by a few days or
more I think the chances are real Mr
President there are members of your
party who would like to see conditions
placed on a to Israel what is your view
on that they would like to see you know
reduction
the well I think that's a worthwhile
thought but I don't think if I started
off with that we'd ever gotten to where
we are today we have to take this a
piece of a Time Mr President do you
trust toas to uphold their end I don't
trust toas to do anything
right I only trust a m to respond to
pressure and to that I say
yeah I think he's totally right actually
it it pains me to agree with Joe Biden
and I saw the big headlines Biden turns
his back on Israel but everything he
said there is
right every I hate it this is might be
the one first time I've ever said this
about Joe Biden not just in his
presidency but in his entire public life
certainly in his public life is longer
than my entire life so certainly since
I've been aware of Joe Biden everything
he said there is right he says I I want
the prime minister to try to minimize
civilian casualties even as he pursues
the legitimate military objective of
completely destroying Hamas totally true
I
have
uh I've I've heard from members of my
party that they want to place conditions
on Aid to Israel I think that's a
worthwhile idea obviously it is there
should be conditions on All American
foreign aid the reason we give foreign
aid is to have influence in the world if
we're not having any influence then
we're just what then we're just then
we're just a blank check for some
foreign country no of course not of
course we want conditions an all foreign
aid coming out of the United States
that's true but he he conditions even
his call for conditional Aid he says but
had I started from that position then
Israel would be in a much worse spot
right now if our objective is to defend
the existence of the state of Israel
then we would be in a much worse spot
right now and so I didn't open up that
way by saying we're going to put
conditions on aid but obviously we
should in the long run totally true and
then finally they say do you trust toas
he says I don't TR Trust mon to do
anything hate to say it but even a
stopped clock twice a day is correct a
monkey sitting at a typewriter long
enough will write King leer and Joe
Biden said something right now the
Democrats are totally misinterpreting
what he's saying here and taking it to
totally illogical places one Democrat
Senator said that us Aid to Israel
should not include bombs do you want any
Aid to Israel that Congress passes here
in the next few months to include
conditions on how it's
used it's fair my position is really
simple I'm all for the Iron Dome it
saved uh it saved many many Israeli
lives I'm all for humanitarian Aid the
more that we can help uh minimize the
loss of life in Gaza uh the better for
Israel and for all of us I'm against the
bombs I mean the 2,000 PB bombs that the
Netanyahu government was dropping on uh
refugee camps where there was massive
loss of civilian life I don't really
think those should be part of our
Aid so are you urging the administration
are you are you telling your colleagues
and the administration uh not to allow
American dollars to be used for those
bombs yeah I don't want to spend money
on those
bombs he he doesn't the guy the Democrat
Senator wants the us to give Aid to
Israel but not
weapons
he does this guy think that Israel needs
us for baked goods is that it Israel
does not need us for baked goods they
make very lovely hos and they what does
he think that we Israel needs us for I
iPads and things do that Israel needs us
so we can send them Ford trucks Israel
doesn't need any of that Aid Israel has
plenty of money and plenty of stuff and
plenty of
food the only only thing that Israel
needs from the United States is Weaponry
is bombs and guns and money that will go
toward those things in fact in fact
every dollar that we give to Israel we
should assume is going toward bombs and
guns because money is fungible and
Israel is facing what it considers to be
an existential War a second war of
independence and so they're going to be
redirecting all of their resources
including their citizenry all of whom
virtually serve in the military at some
point except for the small number of
religious objectors they're going to be
they're going to be directing all of
their resources toward Weaponry so just
be honest about it if this guy is saying
if this guy doesn't think that Israel
should exist as a state and he's got
problems with I don't know how it was
founded how it conducts itself how
whatever whatever his problem is settler
or colonialism whatever then just come
out and say it yeah I don't no weapons
to Israel which means Israel can't
defend itself because Israel is not
self-sustaining Israel requires foreign
aid to exist it's a tiny little country
it's not a world superpower so cut off
the weapons they don't have the the
means to defend themselves then Israel
ceases to exist and they can be H some
leftists are honest about that this guy
does not seem to
be if you're going to give don't fool
yourself into thinking that you're
you're just giving money so that they
can buy new sheets and pillows or
something it's going to guns and weapons
that's what support for Israel means so
look you can even say play we need to
put some conditions on Aid they need to
reduce civilian casualties you can say
all of those things but this this is so
oh man K Kissinger rolling over in his
grave at with this Democrat Senator
saying well I'm all for sending the
money just not for any guns what you're
trying to appease everybody and you're
just spouting complete nonsense now
speaking of wealth got to check out BR
gold right now text nolles to 98.9 8.98
diversify your savings with physical
precious medals while stockpiling silver
in your home save with Birch gold
group's most popular special of the year
now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they
will send you a 1 o Silver Eagle Coin
for free text nolles K wle to 98 9898 to
claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metals Specialists
help you convert an existing ra or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket they will send you
free silver for every $5,000 you
purchase keep it yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year just text the keyword
nolles kwes to 98 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text nolles kws
to 98 9898 claim your eligibility for
free silver on qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that is nolles to
9898 my favorite comment on Friday is
from chesc support 8689 says I love that
this is a 49 minute video titled Dan
santis versus Nome debate summarized in
two
[Music]
minutes Mr Davies I think they're on to
us don't delete that get that out of the
show now speaking of the
presidency a presidential candidate
for the GOP has just picked up a big
endorsement and that would be Nikki
Haley picking up the endorsement of drum
roll
please Paul Ryan do not discount the
Americans for Prosperity endorsement of
Nikki Haley two days ago that's actually
a really big deal and the reason that
that's a really big deal is you could
say that Ron Des Sis's big advantage
over Nikki Hy was his ground game in
Iowa which is impressive America's
Prosperity has an extremely impressive
ground game uh this is the coke networks
um ground game they just gave that to
Nikki Haley so not only does that level
her up in Iowa with Ronda sandz that get
gives her a ground game in all these
other states and the calendar plays to
her Advantage so I'm not saying I'm you
know all for Nikki Haley I'm for beating
Donald Trump I'm for any Republican who
can beat Donald Trump but I think if you
had to pick a growth stock I think Nikki
is the growth
stock whether Nikki haly likes it or not
she is now the establishment candidate
for the
GOP she would fight that label she would
push back on anyone calling her a neocon
or establishment or anything like that
but it's not up to her to quote Henry
Kissinger the die is cast she has now
been endorsed by the coch network which
is the biggest
establishment Chamber of Commerce don't
focus on the social issues kind of
right-wing group and Paul
Ryan and it's even more significant here
because Paul Ryan is on the board of
News Corp which owns Fox
News which means I think Ryan is
probably right that this does level
Nikki Haley up a little
bit the unfortunate thing for her is
that leveling up from right right now
just even in that poll that was cited on
CNBC with with Paul Ryan in the clip
right now Haley is at
%. Ronda santis is at
133% so it levels her up four points to
Ronda
santis is it going to level her up 40
points to beat Donald Trump no there is
no path to the nomination for any
candidate in this race other than Donald
Trump not saying it's a good thing not
saying it's a bad thing but no one has
articulated one the nearest thing we've
heard is people saying Ronda santis is
going to win in Iowa and that's going to
give him momentum to win the nomination
no candidate who won Iowa has won the
nomination for the GOP in over 20
years if you I guess you could count
2004 was the re-elect with George Bush
and he didn't have any any opponents but
for a Challenger cand for a new
candidate it hasn't happened in over 20
years
furthermore they're now saying Nikki
Haley might have a shot at Iowa not that
that would really help her at all either
what's the path I don't see the
path in a way this is a mark in favor of
Ronda santis by the way this is
something I've always said is is one of
the best parts of Ronda santis whom I
really like they say I I the pitch for
Ronda santis was he's the bigger better
Trump bigger better faster stronger more
disciplined more ideologically coherent
sure but that's why the establishment
doesn't like him from the beginning all
the optimists the disantis optimists who
said who said he's the best candidate
because he's going to pull from Trump
and he's going to pull from The
Establishment I said he's going to pull
from
neither he's a man without a home if you
want Trump you're going to vote for
Trump if you want establishment you're
going to vote establishment
DeSantis his best positive is also his
weakness in a primary like this so okay
now they've decided it's going to be
Nikki
Haley which means barring some totally
unforeseen event it's probably going to
be Trump now what about on the other
side there's some Challengers to Joe
Biden is the political establishment
backing away from Biden are they going
to now back Nome are they now going to
back kamla Harris are they going to back
Bobby Kennedy Jr not a chance no
George Soros and his son Alex Soros
who's taking over the George Soros
leftwing financing
Empire they have just maxed out
donations to Joe Biden's 2024
reelect now maxing out donations is a
little bit misleading here because we
have all these weird campaign Finance
rules maxing out donations means they
each gave
$6,600 which is nothing that's the
amount of money they make every time
they blink okay $6,600 is not going to
matter at all to the campaigns now they
had also given a quar million dollar to
the Biden Victory fund which is much
less regulated than the the actual
candidate Campaign Committee but the
reason that they're doing this is not
about the six grand or whatever 12 13
Grand and it's not about even the
quarter million dollars it's about
signaling to the rest of the left that
the big dog funders are still with Biden
the hardest hit person here is Gavin
Nome followed by kamla Harris Pete Budaj
all these other Jokers who want to take
Biden's spot there's still a ton of
support major institutional support for
Biden what's really funny too is you see
on the left basically all despite
Biden's extremely low approval
ratings all of the left the elite and
even a lot of the grass Roots they're
still backing Biden on the right the
entire Elite basically hates Donald
Trump even though he's the guy who's
running kind of as an incumbent he's
leading the pack by 4050 points you're
still seeing these major establishment
Elite networks donating a ton of money
to other candidates even candidates who
are polling at something like 9% you
look at the coke Network and Nikki Haley
shows you just a major difference
between the left and the right the left
pretty much put together marching and
lock step the right at each other's
throats carved up into at least two
maybe three
factions they can't figure it out but
the the people it would appear will
tolerate Joe Biden Joe Biden even
without the superdelegates even without
trying to push Bobby Kennedy out Joe
Biden would still win the nomination
there's no question about that for the
Democrats they would be the people on
the Democrat side would still basically
be in line with the elite and the
leaders on the right the elite and the
leaders are to totally
opposed to the the people in terms of
which candidate they
back 50% or more of of Republican voters
back Donald Trump if you if you pulled
Republican Elites I bet something like
60 to 0% of the Republican Elites
especially the guys with the money
oppose Trump the rest of the show
continues now it is music Monday you do
not want to miss this become a member
use code NES kwes a checkout for two
months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
a